Captain America's Civil War lived up to
all of the hype offering yet another
spectacular entry into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe while the film felt
more like a third Avengers film than the
third Captain America flick we're still
shocked at all the crazy plot twists and
super-powered fights amidst the carnage
there are plenty of references and
easter eggs that you may not have
noticed while you were going at your
favorite superheros going all WWE on
each other as you'd expect there's a
what Conda sized amount of spoilers
ahead so you might want to put this list
on ice if you haven't seen the movie yet
for the birds in the comics
Sam Wilson usually has a pet Falcon
named Red Wing that he brings with him
to the battlefield he has a telepathic
link with the bird that sinks their
brains together allowing Wilson to see
whatever the Falcon sees to make things
simpler Captain America Civil War made
Red Wing a remote-controlled drone that
would fly out of his backpack Wilson
could use his goggles to see from the
perspective of the machine to get a
tactical readout on his surroundings
gotta admit that's a lot cooler than an
escapee from a bird sanctuary
rearranging crossbones
holding the grudge against Steve Rogers
for the events of Captain America Winter
Soldier crossbones attempts to steal a
biological weapon in Lagos Nigeria
eventually the villain gets enclosed and
blows himself up alongside cap in a
heavily populated marketplace scarlet
witch's containment of the blast negates
a lot of the casualties that would have
happened otherwise but some innocents
get killed nonetheless triggering the
government to step in with the sokovia
accords well he may have inadvertently
helped start the civil war in the movie
he does the opposite in the comics after
Steve Rogers turns himself in to the
authorities me know crossbones Snipes
him from afar leading the Cape's death
but don't worry he got better dealing
with Karpov by the book remember that
guy who had the red book with the
passwords that activated the winter
soldiers programming that character is
Vasily Karpov who played a slightly more
important role in the comics Karpov
helped cap file one of red skulls plans
but he also played a pivotal role in
turning and injured Bucky Barnes into
the Winter Soldier community
contributions directors Anthony and
Joseph Russo are known for directing
episodes of Arrested Development and
community prior to their adventures in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
war Jim rash known for playing dean
Craig Pelton on community makes a cameo
and cap Dean America Civil War he played
the MIT liaison who was speaking Tony
Stark after his onstage announcement if
you check out the Russo's previous
Marvel movie the Winter Soldier you may
have recognized avenge himself Danny
Pudi as an agent of shield cool as that
is we're still hoping he shows up on the
big screen as a different comic
character someday
Batman yeah excellent vision in the
comics the vision started wearing
clothes so he wouldn't freak out his
other teammates as much and to try to
blend in more we saw Paul Bettany decked
out in sweaters throughout the Civil War
while he was still wearing the mine
stone on his forehead which makes for
one awesome fashion accessory
furthermore we saw the comic based
relationship between vision and Wanda
continued to flourish from its start and
age of Ultron as the two characters
seemingly cared for one another despite
how weird and chaotic their lives have
been so far moving words we're sure a
lot of you got a little teary-eyed
seeing Steve Rogers mourn as he carried
agent Peggy Carter scoffing at her
funeral Captain America's former
neighbor slash potential love interest
Sharon Carter gives a heartfelt eulogy
for her aunt that might sound familiar
in the comics
Captain America explains his decisions
with the iconic no you move speech in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe cap hears
it from Sharon at a time when he needed
to hear most cementing his resolve and
stance on the sokovia accords may I buy
you a drink sure it was a little awkward
watching Tony Stark hanging out and kind
of flirting with Ma before meeting Peter
Parker but this isn't the first time
Aunt May got cozy with Tony Stark
the 1994 romantic comedy only you
featured Downey and Tomei falling in
love and all that good stuff by the end
of the film is it possible that Iron Man
might become spider-man's uncle in a few
movies iron spider
spider-man originally played an even
larger part in the comic book version of
Civil War siding with Tony Stark
and supporting the superhero
Registration Act spider-man reveals to
the world that he is actually Peter
Parker resulting in all kinds of
problems in the long run for the wall
crawler
fortunately Tony Stark backs him
throughout most of the events even
making a new armored iron spider suit
that featured extra arms and all kinds
of cool dad
during the movie stark finds Peters
original makeshift superhero outfit a
little underwhelming since he's only
been your friendly neighborhood
spider-man for a few months by this time
he ultimately gives him his first real
costume complete with some new toys ant
and Hawk during the film's fight between
the two opposing halves of the Avengers
a miniaturized ant-man gets boosted
toward Ironman by holding on to one of
Hawkeye's arrows this scene is actually
inspired by The Avengers issue number
223 which depicts the awesome maneuver
on its cover but the fight only gets
better when ant-man takes a huge gamble
and becomes giant man in order to create
a big distracting diversion instead of
shrinking to roughly half an inch in
height and man tries a new trick and
turns ginormous what non-comic fans may
not have realized is that Ant Man has a
long history of skipping the small stuff
and going big
he first shrunk down to fun size
proportions as ant-man in 1962 s tales
to astonish number 35 by tales to
astonish number 49 in 1963 he made his
debut Giant Man and fought a lame
villain named the living eraser let's
hope Marvel never decides to bring that
dude into the movies Trading Places
seeing warmachine get accidentally shot
down by vision and lose the use of his
legs was pretty sad these events sort of
mirror what happened between Tony Stark
and James Rhodes in the comics after
being shot and paralyzed Tony Stark uses
technology to help himself walk and move
around
Tony's overall health started to worsen
resulting in him creating the variable
threat-assessment armor which would
become the war machine armor after
everyone thought he died Tony Stark's
will named Rhodes the head of his
company and gave him the new suit now
war machine has become the one
struggling to walk after being shot
which shows a sad but unique twist on
things the raft meant to hold super
villains who are too dangerous for
normal jail cells the RAF's Island Lake
designs were inspired by Alcatraz in the
movie the government takes things a step
further by making the raft entirely
submersible the climactic fight the
movie's title fight breaks down to a
slugfest featuring Captain America and
Bucky versus Iron Man after Bucky gets
disarmed you know
like when he loses his arm Captain
America and Iron Man go all out and one
on one brawl the fight features a
highlighted segment where Tony Stark
fires his repulsor blasts into Captain
America shield recreating the iconic
comic book cover on the big screen back
to basics after scanning and predicting
Captain America's fighting techniques in
record time
Ironman proceeds to beat him bloody with
relative ease after getting trampled
Steve Rogers struggles to get up and we
have a familiar exchange how'd you do
this all day if that sounds familiar
there's a good reason Steve said the
same thing and a free Super Soldier
Serum scene in Captain America the First
Avenger the spider signaled the second
post-credit scene ends up with Peter
Parker nursing his wounds back home in
Queens
while toying around with the new web
shooters Tony Stark even he accidentally
shines a bright red light from the
device which turns out to be the spider
signal old-school comic fans should
definitely be happy to see this calling
card it'd be amazing wall-crawler
basically spider-man would shine this
giant projection of his face onto
unsuspecting villains announcing his
entrance before he swings in to save the
day doing that might make for a more
dramatic entrance than this
hey everyone thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to see
more videos like the one you just saw
and leave us a comment to let us know
which Civil War Easter eggs we missed